the [ __ ] goes down we're all going down
together yeah
Madonna's recent insta post isn't
sitting well with fans that's the theme
of commitment over the weekend the 61
year old pop star shared this video of
herself naked in a bathtub waxing on
about the corona virus outbreak as an
ominous piano played in the background
yeah we're serious that's the thing
about Kovac 19 it doesn't care about how
rich you are how famous you are how fun
you are how smart you are where you live
how old you are
or the amazing stories we can tell and
it kept going it's the great equalizer
and what's terrible about it is what's
great about it
it's terrible about it is it's made this
all equal in many ways and what's
wonderful about it is that it's made us
all equal in many ways she captioned the
not so light hearted post quote no
discrimination kovat 19 and it ended
like this
[Music]
well Madonna received a bit of backlash
for her message
I mean people went off in the comments
one follower wrote quote sorry my queen
love you so much but we're not equal we
can die from the same diseases but the
poor will suffer the most
do not romanticize nothing of this
tragedy another added I still got to go
to work while you are taking a bubble
bath and flower bath bombs and all kinds
of treats other fans seem to struggle
with Madonna's message one commented
quote I love you my queen but things
outside your mansion are very different
from what you think 19 will definitely
make me a more tolerant person but this
bath time post wasn't Madonna's first
one about the coronavirus not even close
what I really miss this is true it's
being able to talk in front of an
audience be funny in front of an
audience every night making people laugh
is fun another luxury gone for now the
singer has shared several clips on
Instagram of her quarantined Diaries
martini Three Olives extra dry to drink
alcohol anything that suppresses
Cherubini system when we get us having
fun and honestly it's relatable AF I
lost track of time
so tomorrow's Saturday wait I miss
interacting with people and then some of
its not artists I'm here cheaters
charities and how should I just start it
down
Madonna shared someone for quarantine
workouts I posted this clip of her seven
year old twins and dancing it out
alongside the caption quarantine
freestyle but Donna's kids took her temp
take your temperature like you mean it
that's a way that is needed
97.5 that is that normal and it appears
she is going stir-crazy just like the
rest of us come go let's go eat some fun
fish fish come on boom I can go let's go
eat some bad fish bad [ __ ] cuz there's
no more pasta Oh No
so we're gonna eat some fried fish we're
gonna share that clip writing living in
special times it's 3 a.m.
cut me some slack people and on that
note good night dear typewriter
and the cities of dreams for all who are
so daring daring daring to dream
[Music]